[Musik]
thüringer bratwurst in zwölf für ihn
aber 29
der xxl double bietmanns herberger den
praktischen zehn kilo sagt für acht euro
wir deutschen wir lieben wright flaschen
60 km 250 gramm denn vielleicht macht
drei kilo co2 die gleiche menge schwein
oder knöchel und dieselbe menge
kartoffeln 80 kilo co2 emission
kartoffeln statt
echt jetzt unser vertrauen summe
deutschland sorgt pro jahr für 42,7
millionen tonnen co2 60 millionen liter
wasser und 29,5 millionen tonnen wenn
also weg aber in deutschland nur ein
viertel weniger fleisch isst spart das
allein schon 6,6 millionen tonnen co2
ganz ohne muss nicht sagt es für unsere
gesundheit und fürs klima voll okay wäre
wenn jeder 300 gramm fleisch pro woche
essen würde also einmal pro woche
fleisch so eine art sonntagsbraten das
probiere ich mal
[Musik]
die landwirtschaft ist mit sieben einer
der höchsten verursacher von
treibhausgasen weltweit
wie kann der umstieg auf ökologische
landwirtschaft gelingen
der ostfriesische landwirt hermann
poppen begann vor einem jahr auf bio
umzustellen
er setzt darauf dass ihm der ökolandbau
langfristig bessere einkünfte liefert in
den neuen stellen haben die tiere mehr
platz als früher
auch die geburts der ferkel kann auf dem
hof jetzt artgerechter laufen in einem
stall gebaut nach bioland richtlinien
[Musik]
125 sein leben heute nach den neuen
standards aufruf sonnenschein die
initiative tierwohl gab bauer poppen
dafür die volle punktzahl
das schafft sonst kaum ein land wird die
umstellung kostet zeit geld und nerven
aber für den landwirt ist es auch
verpflichtung für die nächste generation
den schritt zum biobauern hat er auch
wegen seiner töchter gemacht sie wollen
den hof übernehmen aber nur wenn die
tiere artgerecht gehalten werden
bei kommt sie ja auch verklappen wurden
geboren und jetzt auch stroh dass es
viel schöner
meiner meinung nach war das ist
gemütlicher als einfach hartenstein
ich finde es auch schön weil ein
bisschen zu ruhig
als die noch in den auch die saunen den
kasten stein gelegen haben da waren
immer sehr laut wird man da rein
gekommen ist jetzt einfach so
entspannend und auch die ferkel lassen
sich zu anfang
man kann sie einfach manchmal streiten
sie das bitte schön ob eine vom
aussterben bedrohte schweinerasse ist in
aurich aufruf sonnenschein zu hause die
veränderungen waren für alle eine
herausforderung für mensch und tier
der erste durchgang für die ganzen das
war echt schwierig wir mussten die sauen
an trainieren dass sie nicht draußen
laufen können und dass ihr geschäft auch
draußen erledigen und nicht alles hier
in der bucht
dass das team sauber gehalten werden
muss dass sie sahen hier ab ferkel und
nicht draußen dass wir nämlich auch
gerne gemacht
also sie haben
mal ganz ehrlich sagen eine engere
beziehung zu den tieren als im
kommentarbereich wir müssen es auch
vielmehr um die tiere kümmern nicht 2018
wurden neun prozent der
landwirtschaftlichen flächen in
deutschland ökologisch bewirtschaftet
der biolandbau stift pro hektar nur halb
so viele treibhausgase aus wie die
konventionelle landwirtschaft bio
neuling hermann poppen muss oft erklären
was ökologische landwirtschaft
tatsächlich bedeutet denn damit sich bio
auch finanziell rentiert muss der
konsument mitspielen familie poppen
setzt auf transparenz und öffnet den hof
nach außen die schweine können immer
rein und raus egal waren die können frei
entscheiden
[Musik]
heute sollen sich die nachbarn selbst
ein bild machen können und
nachvollziehen warum sie für bioprodukte
mehr geld bezahlen das was ich hier sehe
dass das lacht das herz in die tiere
gehalten
familie puppenspiel schwein ist teurer
als das fleisch vom discounter aber öko
landwirtschaft schont die natürlichen
ressourcen
am ende kommt das tier mensch natur und
klima zugute
[Musik]
um einen der größten klimakiller zu
bezwingen hat sich eine schwedische
burger-kette etwas ganz besonderes
einfallen lassen
[Musik]
wir können die klimaauswirkungen mit dem
verkauf dieser burger dramatisch senken
[Applaus]
in schweden nimmt man den klimaschutz
nicht erst seit greta team berg ernst
die älteste burger kette des landes
berechnet als erster gastronomie kette
für jedes ihrer produkte den co2
fußabdruck
was an co2 nicht eingespart werden kann
wird seit elf jahren durch
baumpflanzungen kompensiert zu 110
prozent
[Musik]
wir haben 2008 und breiteste
klimaanalyse in der restaurant industrie
durchgeführt
sie deckt alles ab vom feld des bauern
bis zu den händen der gäste die meisten
menschen würden denken dass der
fußabdruck eines baggers wohl von ihnen
strohhalm der benötigten elektrizität
oder vom transport kommt aber
tatsächlich ist dass der bürger selbst
über 50 prozent des gesamten fußabdrucks
von max burger gehen auf das konto des
rindfleisch und das ist in den
rindfleisch bürgern ein rindfleisch
burger erzeugt in der herstellung bis zu
3,5 kilogramm co2 eine vegetarische
variante gibt es ab 0,2 kilo co2
bis 2022 soll jedes zweite verkaufte
gericht der kette fleischlos seien das
wichtigste was wir getan haben ist die
werdende vom klassischen rindfleisch
burger zum veggie burger
hier können wir unsere co2-emissionen um
90 prozent verringern
durch die entscheidung unserer gäste
2015 waren nur zwei prozent unserer
bürger vegetarisch jetzt sind es schon
das ist ein 110 prozentige
verkaufssteigerung und das nur in drei
jahren der erfolg gibt ihnen recht die
klimafreundliche burger kette hat
inzwischen 144 filialen in schweden
norwegen dänemark und polen
richard berg force führt das
familienunternehmen in zweiter
generation seine mission eine
fast-food-kette der welt nicht schadet
meine vision ist dass dem kampf mit den
grossen amerikanischen firmen
aufzunehmen und den menschen zu zeigen
dass man die dinge anders machen kann
und sich nicht schämen muss hierher zu
kommen und fast food zu essen